if anybody has something that they feel
they can't say here in a group setting
that wants a set of time with me super
available there's plenty of time get
[ __ ] done I'm gonna make Monday morning
my [ __ ] can solve like the world's
problems if people actually spend time
together like it's just I believe in it
the most and like I'll tell you guys as
a group right now like if we need to
jump started even more for the ambition
we have like anything I can do to
accelerate that like well you know if
anybody here knows how they bond with
people and I mean things like you want
me to buy you tickets to a baseball game
or you want to go hiking with that
person like I'm open I'm literally open
to anything like I'm willing to pay 150
bucks for you know like a preview
screening of like if you start getting
to know the other individual and you
think you guys have a common interest if
there's a way for me to double up that
common interest let me know actually you
know what I haven't said this in a long
time it's a real mistake and it's how I
built favours foundation everything is
predicated on being the bigger woman and
man in every single situation always and
then using me as the outpost I mean we
can win real big and I'm willing to do
it and now I've clawed to [ __ ] I can
really do it like literally trying to
get into a place where you're the bigger
person in every situation and then
having a place where you can take that
poison out because you want to get it
out you got to eat it is how we built
Bane originally for real that's how I
got the right foundation at first like
just getting everybody religious about I
would be the bigger person like I
disagreed but I'll be the one that bends
right now but then I'm gonna go punch
Gary in the face or Kelly or AJ now now
and Claude is it's a real thing so
that's another thing just to think about
cuz I'm that's exactly what I want to
say to them as well I mean it's insane
there is no separate there should be no
separate I understand physically even
how big this division is leaders like it
makes sense but it's going to be a
constant pressure on everybody from me
in a real way starting very very soon to
not let that happen and so I'm glad and
that I think we had those conversations
in the summer you know 101 things that
nature that allowed some
movement I think in the fourth quarter
is a preview to it and I'm sure some
pockets are good and some pockets
probably exactly the same and that's
okay just won't be able to be bad I
think I think you know there'll be a
meeting probably within two or three
weeks where some of these secondary
details are gonna start getting
addressed so I think it's a really good
time for everybody here to gather their
thoughts have a meeting with these three
so that when they come to that meeting
they're very prepared and like for
example I need to hear other things from
accounting strategy and creative right
now but I'm super excited about
approving that as the standard way we do
things and that's how happen in a world
where this company has no financial
pressure it is insane that we let the
flaws of human behavior cause friction I
mean this should be the happiest place
on earth the financial pressure is taken
out of the equation so like now you're
just letting people's pride and ego and
personalities create friction if we are
truly down to work if if a word or a
number or a slide can cause a flare-up
of any nature a disconnect an argument
an issue humans are bad and end end and
amazing they're bad in the micro and
they're amazing in the macro we're
amazing we're still here we're cruisin
like we could have been eliminated a
long time ago everybody's so sad and
scared about kids on phones and their
think about the micro the macro is we're
fine we just have to do a better job
it's gonna be a big year of really
solidifying this thing where I'm gonna
go back into the micro which will fix it
but it comes out of communication
whatever you've seen whatever you've
seen all you need to do and you should
take the baton it's on you you're the
only person that can change stuff take
the baton and go have a conversation
with all eleven people that you've been
that you think have been affected by it
and over-communicate of like what you
believe in and how good you want it to
be and what you think is the
interpretation of what's coming out of
my mouth you will win that game you'll
win that game because if they're not
looking to hear you and if you've got me
read right you will win that game right
there right no I mean I mean I mean
they're like right Dylan like you really
like you guys really know that it will
win that game if you have the right
intent truly if you are pure to the logo
and to the macro your zero vulnerability
the people that lose here people are not
here either normally almost nine out of
ten times are so insecure in their own
selves that their behavior manifests
into a selfish place which undermines
their ability to succeed here this
company's completely built on emotional
intelligence it's all I've got and it's
super hard to trick me you can be
sliding by for even a year or two the
reason I'm successful in doing things is
I don't box people into a thousand rules
I let them do their thing
then I audit that thing that I try to
give feedback and then we adjust if
they're able to address that feedback
this is why I want to do town halls I
don't want to theoretically if you view
it that way through my brother unlike I
plants or every [ __ ] question we
won't ask every question because people
may be scared ask the hardest of hardest
questions but we will be in an
unbelievable place as an organization in
two years because I think our town halls
are gonna change our culture in the best
way possible there's nothing bad going
on like you know it's like so great like
I don't know what else to say it's so
great like there's just people gonna
have a really tough time like like like
you written like I don't know we're just
doing the right things like I do I think
if somebody gets fired that they tell
their friends here that it was unjust of
course they do who doesn't you got fired
because you don't have self-awareness
that's what led to the vulnerability so
I don't even think they're doing it like
some people like should one hunt like 47
warnings and
still say it like some people just
actually are not self-aware let somebody
come in to me and ask for a promotion
that every single feedback left right
down client and like [ __ ] anonymous
friends from high school is negative so
like yeah and by the way like I said
we'll get it wrong sometimes serendipity
of like the 11 people that are touching
you they were all flawed and you were
okay that actually can happen because
sometimes it's not 11 sometimes it's
four sometimes it's sick sometimes the
client was a jerk but it took a year to
figure it out like but boy are we like
as a net score running a good spot so
I'm gonna make it as awesome for
everybody as possible always I just
would rather take two killers and send
them to a hiking trip than to continue
to pay somebody who's a d player thinks
they're an a player is kind of nice but
weirdly not as nice do you think if you
really understood what was going on you
know like I know what the [ __ ] is going
on like in a way that nobody understands
hey I have natural emotional talent and
B I'm spending a fuckload of money to
collect the data a lot of stuff I'm
doing it's kind of when the answers I
gave you I love to fix up here cuz then
everything ass gets a lot easier I think
everybody tries to fix a sink when the
well is broken nobody's more powerful
than me in the market and genuinely
believe that meaning I'm gonna be busy
because I'm that thing like I'm that
shield I just need to create a lot of
framework so that I don't have to be
involved you'll never see me say that I
know what the creative needs to be I
know the frameworks and the
conversations and the mutual respect and
the thoughts and the business acumen it
needs to be put into these things but
let's not you know like you everybody
has their gripes like and I want to make
sure we curtail ours and I think they're
appropriate just think they're
appropriate on the other side too
got a lot of work to do but it's good
work again all the ingredients are there
now we're closed and I'm gonna have
these conversations so I'm even here a
long time we've spent no time with you
on that like it's gonna be good like I
know what happens next
I've seen this rodeo before very very
very confident
and the speed in which the human
vulnerabilities kick out of the system
when I get this deep is very quickly
like I walk out of rooms like this
sometimes in like fire John you know
what I mean it's gonna be like end by
the way like I'll be careful I don't
make that it's not that extreme but it's
but it's it's gonna be good some the
person I actually have a real belief in
this the person that has the least ego
yeah that's like genuinely my belief the
person that actually cares about the
person on the other side of it way more
than they care about themselves and we
have a whole industry of people that
care about themselves the whole world
that's why I'm it's it's why I'm good at
what I do for a living it doesn't matter
what I think it matters what the other
person thinks and that trumps anything
that I think and then all my behavior
and work goes into trying to figure that
out
humility makes a good storyteller yeah
the hardest which is why it's hard
everybody is such a good storyteller
you'd all be making trillion dollar
movies and living on a boat like like
you know what I mean like like that's
like you know it's like you know like
it's why I love the Internet so much
because the reason so many people didn't
live on a boat was Hollywood is fixed
and corporate America is real but now
kids that are great storytellers that do
have empathy for their audience and
understand their space they make it they
put it out and they've leverage and you
don't get the judge of the Kardashians
or fat Jewish or CNN's documentary of
the 80s as good content the market does
and I love that because we're closer to
that than ever
that's what I think makes a good
storyteller somebody's got a pulse of
culture and then deploys the audience's
point of view not theirs
I everything I think about I take like
my eyes out
and I put my audience's eyes in that's
why I read all my comments that's why I
only have time for that cuz that allows
me to get the qualitative feedback to
understand where I need to take things
I'm sorry brother dictatorship
dictatorship I'm just gonna do it like
you you take the baton that I've just
given you and you try to do as much with
us you can you take what you believe
here you take the belief and you start
reenacting it parroting in in rooms the
people that have done well at Vayner
that have been here for five years
a lot of these they a lot of it still
set and was like but Gary says and it's
kind of cheeky and feels weird but like
that's how they got trained that's what
it became and it's not about like I wish
I could say vaynermedia it's just what
they're used to saying cuz it was so we
were so small you know but like and the
ones that didn't didn't like like didn't
care about the vision they just thought
it was cuz they've been here or like
it's about to work you know but the work
starts with feeding each other well
honey Empire not Empire honey it's a big
thing for me because it makes everything
go faster once you like each other like
the debates take on a different tone
I love debating I love debating it's
really nice when you actually like each
other and the way to get people to
respect each other is to be good at
filtering skills cuz we had a lot of
that problem there's people that
actually liked each other but they
didn't respect the other person cuz they
actually figured it out and they were
right and that became a vulnerability I
think that's why we're seeing some of
the changes we're having you're not fun
it is when you're the real deal you're
not fun it is to be able to back up me
telling you that I'm actually putting in
the work and know everything that's
going on I say that to like let you know
I'm in my [ __ ] like everybody's very
confused about this Gary Vee thing it's
easy I don't do anything
he just follows me around they take the
quotes and they make pictures like I am
the CEO of this company and I work 18
hours a day
so like you know I'll reply and say
we're not going to get this through GP
did this I told them we're in a good
place
let's get this done and then you'll feel
good you just have to communicate in
this company and not to your friend who
has the same issues as you like I always
say I'm like you know who listens to
your complaining your other loser friend
so like it's really good its all-time
good we didn't get here by accident a
lot of you've been around the industry
for a long time this is the single great
success story of digit of social shop
now we're digital but like this is it
we want we did it it was us we are the
general you're the AKQA the Razorfish of
our generation you want like if you care
about add stuff but we're not even
started you know and it happens cuz it's
good
it just takes people a long time to keep
our cynical it's hard to work in a
company I get it but like I don't know
what else besides a ridiculous open-door
policy you can do then you bring in
Claude doing everything I can
don't everything I can but if you're
wired to be cynical or try to make it
bad
that's what's gonna happen you're you're
in charge you know so feel free long the
way the real tance are you you can start
with because I get a lot of email like
hashtag we're making a commercial a TV
commercial
then I'll see it and they have Suakin
filters so let's let's do a little lingo
amongst us for now for next to you know
six to eight weeks while we get this
completely organized the people that
like me the most like in this company
are my assistants and d-roc because they
see it they know all the truths you know
and I really want to eliminate 10 to 30
percent cynicism in our company this
year I just posed my mind that somebody
that I would spend 40 meetings with and
Claude would spend for meetings with and
they would spend three meetings with
Jason like a leader like that and then
they're gonna believe a glass door
review to make their decision of what
they think about to come
like they're really wild you know the
whole fake news thing and all that like
I know that's true humans are weak like
at this they've like want to see
unfortunately so many humans are wired
to what they were taught by their
parents to not trust and look at the
wrong stuff and like think the wrong
things happening eliminate everyday we
have way more people in this company a
good company that's flourishing that are
cynical then are blindly optimistic and
we have a cult dish type leader you know
I'm not confused with my spiel and yet
we have more cynicism from what do you
think's going on in the rest of the
world [ __ ] you know so I'm excited about
the honey Empire I want to do this for
myself and I want to do it for my legacy
I dream that there's a three-year-old
girl right now who's gonna build the
biggest company in the world and she's
gonna build it the way I'm building this
because I prove that you can build a
[ __ ] monster company like this
you